is it okay not to grow your business
it's an interesting question one that
came in from one of my youtube viewers
Jarrah cello who wrote in the say is it
okay not to grow your business anymore
what do you think about it thanks most
entrepreneurs are driven people and we
like setting goals and we'd like going
after something newer and bigger we're
excited by going after new goals and
once we achieve a goal we get a little
depressed and we want to go after
something bigger and you'll often see
this with a lot of entrepreneurs when
they've when they've set a goal for
themselves I want to get this done XYZ
done they'll work like crazy work super
hard to get there and eventually they
achieve it and it's a huge celebration
like I just I just did this yeah I feel
really good about myself we had a great
impact or whatever your goal was and
then they get depressed because they
don't know what to do next until they
find another business or another goal to
shoot for I remember when I had my first
software company we wanted to build it
up to eventually sell it this was part
of our goal and it was a huge struggle
to get this thing up the ground and you
know lost money for a long time and
eventually turned it around and I could
tell you the story if you want it's
buried in a lot of the videos i created
and eventually i sold the business and
it was a huge heart yeah they did it you
know a couple years built this up sold
it off amazing and then it was like well
what do i do next it was it was almost a
depression it's like I put so much into
this and now it's gone and I've got
nothing to do and I had to really
examine in my life what I wanted to do
next and what we're to spend my time
right it sounds like a great problem to
have and I guess it is but it's still a
problem and i eventually stumbled on to
creating this new business of Evan
Carmichael calm and I haven't given up
on that I love that it's
become it's still part of my passion
every day that I live so I'm very
grateful for that but typically
entrepreneurs will hit that point where
they've accomplished their goal and then
they want to do something else I
remember Ted Turner if you read his
story his one main goal was to create
something he would never accomplish in
his lifetime he wanted something far
beyond what was possible in his lifetime
to keep him motivated because he felt if
he accomplished his goal he wouldn't
have anything else to do so he purposely
set outrageous goals and then went out
and attacked them because that's what
inspired him now this is most
entrepreneurs we like chasing goals we
like achieving you like more we like
building bigger but it doesn't have to
be and the answer really depends on you
there's nothing wrong with being at your
level and there's a certain love of
work-life balance that you can have this
certain level of impact you can have and
maybe you want to work with people more
intimately more one-on-one than helping
the masses and that means you're
spending your time right one on one
instead of helping tons of people but
it's more intimate more direct maybe
that's where you get your satisfaction
obviously you need to get to a certain
point where you can survive right if
this is going to be your full-time gig
you're not going to work at some company
you have to make enough from your
business to support yourself once you
get past that survival point it's really
up to you how big do you want this to be
what are you all about and whatever
answer feels right in your heart that's
the answer there's nobody that should
convince you one way or the other or
make you feel bad for not growing bigger
if you don't want to grow bigger be a
fantastic great small company that you
like your work life balance you'd like
the impact you're having your community
and be confident and proud of that and
don't let other people drag you down if
they think you should be bigger when you
don't want to be
you're contrarian to most entrepreneurs
but I love it it's great to see and
that's what we do is entrepreneurs you
know we challenge the status quo we make
things different and we have a view of
the world that is different than what it
is today and we reach to go out and make
that happen so it's a great question and
there's nothing wrong with not wanting
to grow if you don't want to believe for
you guys watching you like the video
please give it a thumbs up below I love
seeing those come in and please let me
know what you think leave a comment
underneath let me know what's on your
mind let me know if you have a question
I'd be happy to answer for you thank you
so much and I will see you soon